hi everybody this is Nick Gillespie with
reason I am joined by Zach weismiller my
colleague Ed reason Zach aye and today's
guest is vinay Prasad he is a professor
of epidemiology and biostatistics at
University of California San Francisco
he's the author of two books including
one on ending medical reversal or
getting rid of bad medical practices and
malignant and he has been an outspoken
critic of the public health
establishment uh During the covid period
vinay thanks for talking reason thanks
for having me uh let's get right to it
you have a a very popular and Urgent sub
stack uh really vinay prasad's
observations and thoughts uh one recent
um uh article that we wanted to talk
with you about uh because it opens up
the conversation we're hoping to have
today about what went wrong with the
official covid response what went right
with it but most importantly how do we
make sure we don't screw it up the next
time when something like this happens
and we build on our successes rather
than replicating our failures endlessly
but this is from February 17th and it's
headline Public Health should lose your
trust can you kind of summarize the
argument there
yeah I think this this is in an article
that that sort of makes the argument
that we should trust institutions in so
far as their past performance and
unfortunately Public Health by that I
mean the institutions of Public Health
the CDC the National Institutes of
allergy infectious disease niad which
Tony fauci ran
um and even some local public health
officials should lose your trust because
of their poor performance and I go on to
detail you know seven domains where I
think we can all agree they really
underperformed and maybe even in fact
told us some falsehoods along the way
and I'm happy to run through those yeah
well why don't we um Zach do you want to
start with like what you you find most
pressing but you know one of the
questions I guess that we'll come back
to again and again Van Nuys how much of
this is that public health authority
didn't have good information and they
weren't willing to cop to that so they
were you know they thought it would be
too complicated for people to understand
well you know what uh you know know
masks don't work or they would give an
issue you know an order early on or they
would talk about how don't bother about
wearing masks because they're not really
important and then somebody like fauci a
little bit later says well I was
misrepresenting what I thought to be
true because I didn't think people could
understand how much of it is official
dissembling and how much of it is kind
of government or or public health
authorities not being able to cop to the
fact that they don't really know what to
do and they're giving you their best
case scenario at this point in time
well I mean let's just run through that
example so fauci early March 2020 he
says you know on 60 Minutes very
prominently
um we don't advise Community masking we
don't know if you might be touching your
face and have some compensatory behavior
that sort of undoes any benefit masking
might have six weeks later he goes and
says you know what I was I was telling
you something false been initially it
was a noble lie I'll tell you the truth
now which is that you ought to cloth
mask tear a piece of fabric and put it
over your nose and mouth the irony is
actually it was the second time that he
was lying it was the first time he was
telling the truth you know the first
time he was going with the pre-pandemic
body of knowledge he was going with
multiple randomized trials from
influenza the second time under sort of
a heavy pressure campaign from I think
Advocates that we ought to do something
he started to recommend a mask that now
we know clearly cloth masks I don't
think anyone debates they don't work and
they didn't do anything we have a
Cochrane review that just came out that
says any Community mask recommendation
doesn't appear to work in all of the
pooled studies and that's the highest
quality evidence we have to date
so your question is you know did he know
he was lying the second time I suspect
he did actually and why was he doing it
well one reason is if you go and say
well you know I'm not sure but we've
shifted we think maybe give it a shot
people might not really comply so you
have to really sell it the problem with
that I think is that we live in a free
Society where you don't get to deceive
the American public because it is a
democracy we should be presenting you
know fair and balanced information so
people can make the right choices the
second thing that's a problem is you
only get to lie once I mean you lose all
credibility and he has become a
polarizing figure he thinks that's
because there's some conspiracy against
him but to some degree it's the result
of his own actions can I ask to follow
up and to balance fauci say with Donald
Trump who you know who convened a panel
of experts including fauci that you know
we're having daily press conferences was
it problematic that Donald Trump uh at
the beginning of the pandemic was saying
hey this isn't a big deal this is going
to be over by Easter don't worry about
it too much Etc and and was Trump do you
think Trump was acting out of noble lies
or was he acting out of you know he just
he couldn't admit that he didn't really
know what was going on
I think uh whole textbooks could be
written trying to understand what makes
Donald Trump and I think he's a harder
person to sort of interpret but you know
I think he may have genuinely believed
that the pandemic would blow over I mean
he was wrong he certainly wanted it to
be the case right he was wrong to
believe that I don't think science would
suggest that that would be the case in
fact everyone was saying that this is
going to be a long and year-long and a
multi-year-long problem
um but I think we have to acknowledge
one thing which is that he is such and
is such was such a polarizing figure it
was such an anxious time that many
people really anchored into doing
whatever the opposite he said so if
Trump says schools are safe they got to
be dangerous if Trump says you don't
need to wear a mask it's got to work
super well and I fear that to this day
so much of our pandemic Legacy is merely
doing the opposite of what he says but
even a broken watch is right twice a day
and some things he was right about
schools he was right about Massey was
right about
the topic that is still kind of a live
Topic at this point because it masks
thankfully are mostly in the rear view
right now but
um vaccines are still an active issue
and um it's there's become a lot of con
over time there's been a lot of
confusing messages about it there's kind
of the the data is confusing for the lay
person and I to get into that
conversation I like to just play you
some of the Montage of clips of the CDC
director Rachelle wolenski talking about
vaccines over time and get your reaction
to that uh you know in in the context of
what you were just talking about
um the the proper way to communicate
publicly and and the way that if you're
constantly you know backtracking or
fudging things then it can kind of
bounce back on you but um here's
Rachelle wolenski is that if you're
fully vaccinated you are protected
against severe covid hospitalization and
death and are even protected against the
known variants including the Delta
variant circulating in this country just
last month the CDC and the FDA both said
we would not need booster shots What
specifically has changed in the data
that has changed your guidance
right several things so first in the
last six weeks we have seen Delta in
this country we have seen now evidence
that we've been looking at just over the
last week or so that has demonstrated
that the vaccine is starting to wane in
its Effectiveness against infection I I
don't want to say never but we are not
necessarily anticipating that you will
need this annually and it does look like
after this third dose you get a really
robust response and so we will continue
to follow the science a new vaccine with
a new approach for most Americans that
means one covid-19 shot once a year each
fall we are simplifying our message the
message is you need to get your fall
booster vaccine so go ahead and get it
if you're if you're over the age of 12
if you've received your primary series
if you're more than two months out of
your last shot you can get an updated
vaccine and so we've intentionally
simplified the message so it's very very
clear
what do you think of the job that the
CDC and Rachelle Lewinsky have done as
it pertains to the vaccine rollout
I think it's been very poor and deeply
troubled it's the characteristics of a
speaker who's decided what she wants the
public to do and then reasons back to
the sort of messaging that she should
deliver rather than somebody looking at
the scientific facts and just telling
you what we know and what we don't know
and what we still uncertain we can go
back to the beginning the first six
months of 2021 as vaccine rollout
started to take place you know in the
first four months we were Supply
constrained meaning not everyone who
wanted one could get one right away we
made a number of mistakes around who
should be prioritized we prioritized a
lot of young healthy people over older
people we made mistakes about dose two
the United Kingdom stretch dose two out
which actually provides more durable
antibody levels and has better safety
than putting the two doses together
those doses were arbitrarily picked very
close together because we needed the
trial to result quickly in 2021 by the
summer of 2021 it was a parent from
Provincetown Massachusetts and other
instances that you would get people who
were vaccinated were still able to catch
the virus and transmit the virus that
means all the mandates that happened in
the fall which was when Biden pushed the
mandates were medically unethical
because you cannot compel an
intervention on a third party if it
provides sorry you cannot compel a
medical invention on somebody unless
there is a benefit to third parties but
by the fall of 2021 we knew that that
wasn't the case now I want to point out
we could have made Pfizer answer the
question in the randomized trial Pfizer
ran in 2020 we could have asked them to
swab people randomly and their
households randomly and we would have
had an estimate of transmission but over
and over again you'll see that to some
degree both administrations give the
companies the benefit of the doubt the
easiest path forward now let's talk
about boosters this country is unique
that we have a singular focus on
boosting everybody from 12 year olds to
six month olds to 86 year olds whereas
in Europe a number of nations have
focused primarily on older vulnerable
people that makes a lot of sense the
European strategy our strategy does not
make sense not supported by evidence
she's being criticized by people like
Paul offit who he himself makes vaccines
and her rhetoric throughout all this is
always too certain and States things
that she does not know to be true I mean
there are video clips of her saying we
know you can't spread the virus she
didn't know that to be true when she
said it and it turned out not to be true
um can I ask about that I mean at the
beginning and I uh we interviewed Jay
bhattachary a while ago and one of the
things he was saying which corresponds
with what you're talking about is that
the public health authorities at the
highest levels oversold the vaccines not
the vaccines definitely work to reduce
the severity of you know they might
reduce transmission they definitely
reduce the severity of the covet that
you get if if you've been vaccinated and
that's really important because a lot of
people are now just saying like all
vaccine you know the vaccines don't do
anything other than you know cause
people to go insane or or die
um but that they oversold from the
beginning the efficacy of the vaccines
in terms of stopping transmission
Etc because they didn't have faith that
people would get the vaccine if they had
merely been told get the vaccine and you
won't die from covid you might still get
it you might even be hospitalized but at
much lower rate do you think is was that
the the original problem that the
authorities knew these vaccines are not
traditional vaccines and that they keep
you from getting something but they
thought that message was too complicated
to sell to the American people
that's a tough question I mean I I
definitely think you're right uh in the
sense that uh older people do benefit I
mean the benefit of the vaccine in first
quarter 2021 is tremendous for 80 year
olds seven-year-olds 60 year olds I
think one of the challenges is we to
this date don't really know what the
lower limit of benefit is how much
benefit young people are getting
particularly young people who've had
covid we're not honest even people like
40 right I mean you know I mean you're
you're kind of talking about how it's
there's like it it there's a slope that
gets pretty quickly if you're over 60 or
whatever uh coveted vaccine is much more
important than if you're under 40. yeah
and it's particularly true with boosters
and it's particularly true once you've
already hadn't recovered from the virus
you know and and so those are sort of
salient points
um I think there may have actually
genuinely had some optimism that this
could halt to transmission
um because Hope Springs Eternal among
human beings but things that would have
led them to doubt that is that we
continually get reinfected with
coronavirus it's evolves in such a way
you can get it multiple times in your
life and they didn't build into the
studies the sort of the way you would
actually document halting transmission
you know those sort of random swabbing
of people to see that transmission is
halted now I want to point out a few
things I think transmission is lowered
with covid-19 vaccines in the first half
of 2021 it was dramatically lowered by
vaccination but escaped variants like
Omicron basically blast right through
vaccines I mean you can get infected
with Omicron even if you had the
vaccination we still believe it has a
reduction in severe disease so it's good
that you had gotten it but it has no
ability to contain curtail spread and
now the idea that each additional
booster will do something I think some
people believe like you know it's going
to prevent variants from forming that's
naive thinking I mean there's eight
billion people on the planet 100 billion
interactions the virus is going to be
with us for 10 000 years and any
boosters you give is is going to be like
spitting in the ocean it's not going to
do anything for viral mutations yeah you
designed a study that looks at uh it's
called covid-19 vaccine-induced
myocarditis and young males uh
systematic review and we'll get a little
bit more into this myocarditis issue in
a second because that's current that's
seems to be the most Salient concern
that people have with with on the safety
side of the vaccines but the the
interesting aspect of this study is it's
designed to look only uh it's it's
designed to age
well it's designed to stratify among a
bunch of different variables one is age
one is the brand of vaccine you got the
manufacturer another is which type of
dose you got and I I gotta say that this
is one thing that's been really baffling
to me about the entire pandemic is the
lack of stratification in multiple areas
not looking at very specific
sub-populations or vaccine Brands
um it's like everyone must do the same
thing and act as if they're at identical
risk
what before we get into the study like
what do you do you do you agree that
with me on that and if so like what
explains that that kind of
one-size-fits-all approach that that
seems to have uh covered many areas of
the pandemic
yeah no I totally agree with you on the
premise and I think this is the original
sin of the pandemic is that people like
Jay and Martin who proposed some sort of
differential protection more protection
for those who need it less for those who
uh will have better courses with
covid-19 keep schools open like the
Swedish approach that sort of focus
protection that was demonized in this
country we needed a one-size-fits-all
lockdown and all of our policy sins have
been one size fits all the 18 year old
man has to have the exact same number of
doses as the 88 year old woman actually
maybe even have four instead of five for
instance but almost the same and the
point of our article was well we're
talking about where's that Tipping Point
trade-off
um there is a risk of vaccines it is
myocarditis inflammation of the heart
it's non-trivial I mean people can say
it's mostly mild I think that's a very
dishonest thing to say because if you're
a healthy person taking a medical
product you don't want to end up
hospitalized with inflammation of your
heart muscle I think it's a very severe
outcome and there are some people who
have suffered very severe myocarditis
episodes and that's something that we
have to minimize and take seriously it's
a serious safety concern so where's the
Tipping Point
um in terms of risk benefit by age and I
think that was what we were talking
about a little bit before certainly men
are at higher risk than women of
myocarditis Modera appears to be higher
risk than Pfizer perhaps because the
dose is higher
um men in a certain age group you know
the 16 to 24 demographic yeah you'll see
here uh they're at the absolute highest
risk of myocarditis uh old an 80 year
old woman is at a very low risk of
myocarditis for her the net benefit of a
vaccine is large but when you talk about
a 20 year old college man what's the
risk benefit balance of dose one dose
two dose 3 and dose four and does it
change because each additional dose is
not providing as much benefit as the
first dose and I think very likely it
does change along the way for a young
man and our policy is actually
detrimental for young men keep getting
Perpetual boosters that's not just my
opinion that's the opinion of Jay and
Martin Marty mcary and many others and
we published a peer review article on
this so I I think to your point is well
taken medicine has always treated 20
year old men different than 80 old women
we don't take the same blood pressure
pills and we don't take the same statins
we need different vaccine policies as
well it's it's amazing too when you look
at the CDC data or you know official
data on the number of deaths from coven
or with covet or however you want to
measure it and when you're looking under
18 I mean it's still I think under a
thousand for the United States out of
you know over a million deaths
attributed to covid what I mean is it is
it I guess we go back to this question
again and again and if we could ask them
we would but I mean is it that people
like fauci and uh or uh Rachelle
wolinski and whatnot is it that they
don't understand what you just said and
that like this affects people under 21
differently or under 20 that it does
people over 60 or is it that they don't
care and they don't think that any of us
are smart enough to be like well if I'm
over 60 I probably should get the
vaccine if I'm under 20 I can wait or or
I have to weigh in more factors
yeah this is why I wrote the article
they should lose your trust because if
they really don't understand that then
they're grossly incompetent for the job
because this is a basic medical fact you
know that that risk will vary you know
thousand-fold by age and that the risk
benefit calculus of a vaccine with the
harm May tip and if they do understand
it but they nonetheless try to have
force a one-size-fits-all message they
should lose your trust because they're
being dishonest to you and you know you
can fool some people for some of the
time but you can't fool everyone forever
and eventually more and more people are
going to come out and pointing to these
errors and that's going to lead to a
bigger problem which is a cataclysmic
loss of trust in public health so I do
think they've made a a huge
miscalculation and just make proof of
that you have the resignation of Marion
Gruber and Phil Krauss this is the
director and Deputy direct vaccine
products at FDA post they held for
decades they have resigned over this
administration's booster policy in the
fall of 2021. that should signal to
people that this is heavily disputed
among experts these are the vaccine
Experts of the FDA they're being
steamrolled into a one-size-fits-all
policy and I just want to point out who
benefits from that policy the company
benefits a great deal because it's a
huge Perpetual market share and who's
hurt by that policy well I think that 20
year old man who attends a liberal arts
school who's being forced to get a
booster and one in ten thousand maybe
one in 20 000 will get vaccine-induced
myocarditis and that person may have
already had covid and it stands to gain
nothing from that additional booster so
that man is harmed I want a contrast
what the official line or advice is
about the vaccines with what you are
saying because what it more or less is
and I'm going to play the clip of
Rochelle wolinski in a second talking
about myocarditis and and display some
of the cdc's messages about this but
it's basically like okay this is a my
there's there's a mild risk but in the
big picture uh you know you can get my
myocarditis from the infection itself
there's lots of other bad things that
can happen from the infection itself so
we need to just simplify the message and
say you're better off getting the
booster than not so let me play this
clip from Rochelle wolenski and then
have you respond to that line of
argumentation parts of this rare but
mild myocard I just come in and we heard
about this yesterday at the advisory
committee on immunization practices
yesterday but what we do when we do this
is we look at the risks and we look at
the benefits and to just put this in
perspective if we have a group of 12 to
17 year olds who are working to
vaccinate over the next four months and
we can vaccinate a million of them which
would be great strides over the next
four months we could expect 30 to 40 of
these mild self-limited cases of
myocarditis and for that if we were to
vaccinate all one million we would avert
8 000 cases of covid 200 hospitals
50 ICU stays and one death and so we
weigh the risks as well as the benefits
these extraordinary benefits of vaccines
as we make these recommendations and it
is why we at CDC have made the
recommendations to vaccinate and had
co-signers from so many other medical
organizations including the American
Heart Association
so that on its face that argument makes
sense is there something wrong with her
math
yes that's exactly right so I mean her
premise is correct that every time you
take any medical product you gotta weigh
the potential upside against the
potential downside and even if there's
downside if there's more upside it's
still in your best interest to take it
so we all agree on that premise but the
problem is there are errors in her math
uh all of their math is nothing but
errors a few things they conceptually
get wrong one is that you don't have to
give in in their modeling a lot of the
times it's all or nothing it's either
four boosters or no shots at all I
personally think that the vast majority
of adults benefit from dose one dose two
is when I start to struggle with for 20
year old men and those three and dose
four you know I have different cut
points you know so it can vary by dose
depending on your modeling number two we
only really know with sort of good
Precision the reduction in severe
disease in the first two doses that's
what we tested in a randomized fashion
for boosters and for the fourth the
bivalent booster we're doing sort of
retrospective looks in other words we we
don't actually run an experiment to see
what the efficacy is we just let people
get it and we go after the fact and say
hey let's compare people who got it to
people who didn't get it and see how
they do okay let me bring up like this
this slide real quick because I know
that you you analyzed this this is a CDC
slide uh and it's to the point that
you're saying you're talking about
they're saying that per million doses of
the this is of the bivalent booster uh
in 12 to 17 year olds over six months
there's the numbers of hospitalizations
ICU admissions prevented one zero to one
death permit prevented and then in red
at the bottom zero myocarditis cases so
that's the message coming from the CDC
but you're saying that these studies are
just they're garbage they're not
designed properly yeah so I mean this is
a model it's based on like all the
models we've had in the pandemic that
you know wildly inaccurate oftentimes
it's based on your assumptions and so
what they're assuming is rape
hospitalization from the past that are
going to go forward into the future
unchanged but of course that's going to
be different because more people have
had and recovered from covet so that's
going to be lower what they assume is a
vaccine Effectiveness so that this
bivalent booster will lower your risk of
severe disease that they're actually
getting from an older age group and
extrapolating to a younger age group
they're getting it from this sort of
backwards looking kind of study that has
a bias in it and that bias of course you
know Zach and Nick the bias is that
people who choose to get the booster are
different than those who don't in other
ways than the booster I mean they're
usually more precautious people they're
people who may have higher socioeconomic
status they may more likely to be
liberals who live in certain cities you
know for instance and those other
differences might play the role not the
by billion booster itself so you have a
sort of dubious estimate of
hospitalization dubious estimate of
vaccine efficacy extrapolating to a
younger age group and then let's talk
about the harm Side Of The Ledger she
says zero harms out of the 48 000 doses
but they can't actually believe the harm
will really be zero it will be something
when you give it to more people and
allow more time for follow-up my best
guess as to what that something will be
is one in ten thousand because that's a
very nice estimate from the third dose
in in roughly this age group from the
Kaiser Permanente group so
again you know these types of exercises
modeling in science it's the most
malleable science you can bend and flex
it and I can make my own analysis that
would probably reach a different Tipping
Point than hers the problem is that the
person doing this modeling has a already
decided on the policy they've already
decided that these vaccines have to be
given to this age group and then they do
the modeling and that's very problematic
because if we know where we want to go
we can get the model to give us the
result is there any world where this you
know in an alternate universe how would
this have been accomplished how would
quality Studies have been accomplished
because you you do understand like I can
understand from their perspective we're
in an emergency situation it's a
pandemic people are dying getting
hospitalized all the time so we don't
have time to do these high quality
randomized control trials might be the
argument is there anything to that and
you just kind of have to deal with the
uncertainty yeah so I think it's a
Perpetual argument and there's always
two things they say we don't have the
money and we don't have the time the
money I think we'll all concede they
have because Pfizer and modern have 100
billion reasons they can make this
happen the time is the question how long
do these studies take and my answer is
the following simple thing they debuted
this bivalent booster in the fall I
believe in September and we still have
14 uptake nationally in age groups so
you know what's the point of rushing
something that nobody wants anyway the
next thing I'd say is that randomized
studies actually don't take as much time
as you think just think about the
initial vaccine trial which was launched
sort of in the summer of 2020 and yield
a result by the Fall
um if you increase the number of people
you give it to you'll get a result even
faster
I think it's inexcusable that they don't
do they don't make the company do those
studies the company is going to make
money for you know year after year
billions of dollars uh they can afford
to do it we can have the infrastructure
to do it and by doing those studies I
think you will learn the reality and my
guess is the reality is that the the
benefit of these products year after
year after year is going to be smaller
than what they think it is can we talk a
little bit about the relationship
between the pharmaceutical companies and
and the government and the policy
because you've written that you know one
of the great successes of the covet
pandemic uh which has been really
obscured is the fact that the uh the
disease was sequenced very quickly and
we brought effective vaccines to Market
incredibly quickly you know shots into
arms
um but that seems to be
um you know very uh one of the reasons
why that's kind of obscured or or it
moves to the back
um is because of the conditions that
were attached to the development and the
follow-up of the problems could you
could you talk a little bit about what
went right with operation warp speed and
then where you know you you've mentioned
a couple of times so that Pfizer and
moderna and other vaccine makers are
aren't required to do continuing kind of
studies and things like that but you
know talk about what went right and then
why it's you know the follow-through is
not where it should be according to you
yeah and um I guess I just want to say
that what we're getting at is sort of an
age-old principle of medicine which is
we have interventions that work really
well in very sick people that sometimes
the manufacturers of course their
interest is to just use it in more
people and as you get to people who are
less and less sick they work less and
less well and at some point the Harm's
outweigh the benefits we see that with
you know stenting heart attacks works
wonderfully stenting people with just a
touch of angina you know might not work
well at all and that's the age-old
principle of medicine so let's talk
about operation warp speed I think it
was you know remarkable success they
really expedited the development of the
MRNA vaccine in a time frame that even
the optimists thought was implausible
and there's no doubt about it I mean
people at the time and it's it's weird
because it's not long ago but it feels
like a million years ago but people were
talking about you know three years five
years to really get a vaccine that's up
and working and things like that and you
know there it is in a few months there
it is right around the election yeah and
um yeah well just after right well we
should talk about that because Pfizer
made a addendum to their trial um so uh
but it was remarkable that they were
able to run the randomized trial in such
a short fashion operation warp speed was
a success they were sort of uh given
money to make sure they wouldn't suffer
losses and so that they would take that
investment risk and I have no doubt
about it that the vaccine saved many
many lives including American lives
particularly older vulnerable people now
the questions we're arguing about today
is a different question that was 2020
the fall we had a a wave that led to
horrific deaths the vaccine had come out
a few weeks sooner we would have averted
some of those deaths we could talk about
that but right now we did at reason I
mean the you know the fact that like the
FDA took Thanksgiving weekend off
to you know pushing things back even you
know even by the day it's you know you I
I'm sorry to interrupt but it's no
you're right we have two you know we
have two agencies particularly the CDC
but also the FDA they exist for exactly
this type of situation and then they
were like well you know what it's
quitting time today we'll see you on
Monday I it's it's insane making to be
quite honest but it's insane and the
original Pfizer study was gonna have a
statistical look at 30 events and then
they moved it to 60 events in an
amendment that actually delayed it until
after the election and these two choices
I detail in that essay you put up
actually significantly delayed vaccine
rollout it could have come out several
weeks before and I think you're right
that when it's an emergency you don't
take any days off and you work around
the clock and if we need to reschedule
people's shifts so be it
um but now we're in a different
situation I mean I think we all agree
there was a covid-19 emergency but does
anyone think there's an emergency for
healthy 12 to 15 year olds in 2023
February I think I'd be hard-pressed to
find anyone who can genuinely look you
in the eye and tell you there's an
emergency so I think the eua authority
that emergency use authorization should
not be allowed for vivalent boosters in
a 12 year old because they're not facing
any emergency we can go back to the
traditional Pathways of drug development
and I so I guess the debate about
vaccines has been so polarized they're
either as you point out they're going to
murder you in your sleep you know and
and cause you to have every problem or
there are
spoons will be sticking to your head and
stuff yeah or they're a Panacea and you
should get as many as experts recommend
and if they recommend them every two
months you should get them every two
months even if you're six months old you
know that so these are the two extremes
of the debate but the truth about
medicine is that all medical
interventions work well for some people
and some people you can do too much of a
good thing and get into trouble so I
think that's the debate yeah what do you
think went into the you know I guess the
negotiation is the right phrase for it
but you know what went into the
negotiation between the government uh
and the pharmaceutical companies in
terms of saying okay we're gonna we're
gonna immunize you from a bunch of legal
liability which you know I I and I say
this as a Libertarian I think I
understand where that's coming from and
it makes sense that's one thing and then
to say we're also going to we're not
going to force you to do continual you
know studies on what's working or at to
what extent you know to what population
and things like that you know were the
government negotiators are they just
completely captured by the
pharmaceutical companies or again you
know and I guess maybe this is the wrong
question asked because I don't know that
we can answer or you know were they you
know are they captured by The Regulators
or are they just being mendacious and
they're actually Servants of of the
pharmaceutical companies
um you know and they're they're
pretending that they don't know what
they should be doing
I think many people have talked about
this problem in FDA I mean we did an
analysis in the bmj where we looked at
where do the reviewers at the FDA go
when they leave the FDA and the answer
is more than half uh go to the
pharmaceutical industry and we saw it
with Stephen Han he's at a VC firm that
has investments in moderna
Gottlieb Scott Gottlieb he works on the
board of Pfizer and I suspect you'll see
that this cast of characters will soon
transition to these same firms whose
products they expedited I think many
people view the client as the
pharmaceutical company not the American
people and they view their job to
streamline these things you talked about
indemnification I think indemnification
made sense at a time where you were
getting frivolous MMR lawsuits for
measles mumps and rubella all the time
but does indemnification still make
sense when you're getting preschools
mandating vaccine boosters and young
children so kids can go to a summer camp
or a daycare I personally think I don't
I'm not comfortable with letting some
mid-level bureaucrats in an Upstate New
York summer camp and decide what
vaccines should be mandated I think they
should be legally liable for any
consequences of that mandate right could
you also you you touched on this earlier
and it's a really important point that
when when the vaccine does not actually
help a third party
um there's there's no grounds for a
mandate from a public health perspective
could you just explain that a little bit
because that's another Dynamic here that
I think has gone missing in a lot of
these discussions and it's absolutely
Central to what what is a legitimate
kind of public health model and mandate
and you know what we've been
experiencing yeah so I guess I want to
say one thing right off the bat that
even if it does affect third parties
favorably you should still weigh the
risks and benefits of doing it but if it
doesn't affect third parties favorably
you can't start you can't pass go and
what I mean is medical products that
pills you take vaccines you take devices
you put in your body they can only be
man like an ethical prerequisites to
mandate it they can only be considered
for mandate is if they provide a benefit
to third parties and the third party
benefit has to be so large it outweighs
the loss of individual freedom and
autonomy and this is not a new principle
this has been there for you know 50 60
years of medical ethics and when they
did mandate this vaccine they knew that
it could not prevent transmission so I
think they didn't have the ethical
prerequisite to mandate it all the
booster mandates I think are ethically
troubled Troublesome uh it doesn't halt
transmission some people say Well it
transiently reduces transmission 20 so
therefore there is a benefit to third
parties that doesn't make a lot of sense
because when we're around for two years
years we're all going to get coveted
anyway so what is the benefit of
potentially delaying it by three weeks
or something and you know for the
individual you can make that decision
you can say this is I think that or I
believe or I know this is going to
reduce my chance of hospitalization and
death or whatever what are what are the
the best examples of a mandated vaccine
or or public health intervention that
has actual that fits the ethical
criteria that you just laid out yeah I
mean I think I would say the measles
vaccine fits that criteria and I'll tell
you why
um it does because
if the amount of children who are
measles vaccinated is above a certain
threshold measles will literally go away
we won't have an outbreak of measles at
all but it takes that certain threshold
to be hit and so you can argue that by
getting it to that threshold with
compulsion with mandates we actually
benefit a lot of third parties because
no kids are getting measles you know and
so that's a sterilizing vaccine those
mandates are often in place in school
districts and I think it fulfills the
ethical prerequisite
um this doesn't because you can mandate
it all you want and people are still
going to get covet 19. now some people
argue that actually we should have a new
version of mandates that if I think it's
in your best interest I should be able
to mandate it on you the problem I have
with that is it's a slippery slope so I
can come to your house and tell you what
you should eat and tell you to take your
blood pressure medicines and actually
supervise you swallowing them and that's
something that no one has ever accepted
in medicine and it's something that I
think nobody wants and so we don't do
things I mean we let people make bad
choices you can drink too much you can
smoke if you want you can eat poorly we
let people make those bad choices that's
what it means to be in a free Society
but we only mandate it if there's a
compelling benefit to third parties the
last thing I just want to say on this
issue is I think even if it stopped
transmission I wrote editorials saying
that in America in the in the political
climate we're in the juice wasn't worth
the squeeze I mean it it the the
political consequences of forcing a very
novel product on a huge or on a chunk of
American people
um would have long-term deleterious
implications and the last thing I want
to say is I don't think the Mandate
actually increased uptake that much
there's a trend in uptake pre-mandate
they mandated it and then they take
credit for anything post-uptake but you
know it was going to go up anyway I
estimate probably two to three percent
of people got it just by virtue of the
Mandate from the workforce and that's
although it is also true that I mean the
uh in a historical context the uptake of
the covet vaccine is just off the charts
it took polio vaccines MMR et cetera
decades to get to where where the
coveted vaccine basically got in less
than a year we're the most pro-vac
Society in any time in human history
yeah you're right and I think that's
something people Miss because we talk so
much how anti-vaxx we are but no one has
ever uptake a vaccine as quick as this I
do take it if I just may I mean to go
back to Trump a little bit you know part
of the confusion you know and it's
people like fauci you know who's taking
a massive amount of abuse and I think
legitimately so wolinsky uh what not
um you know but Trump it's very peculiar
the way that he was you know I am doing
operation warp speed but I don't really
believe covet is is that serious and I
don't know about these vaccines and now
you know because Ron DeSantis is
anti-vaccine Donald Trump seems to be
pro-vaccine uh you know it's it there's
you know from the very top there was
this kind of ambivalence about what do
we do uh that I think as you were
pointing out a lot of people if Trump is
doing it then I'm against it uh Vice you
know and vice versa so
um yeah I mean I completely agree with
you that in those months when you watch
Trump in the press conferences you may
have felt more uncertain and more
nervous because he discussed it so
flippantly uh covet's no big deal just
maybe some maybe bleach will hell I
don't know maybe bleach will help maybe
light will help I mean he's speculating
in front of national audience uh and so
of course that's going to be unnerving
when people are seeing casualties and
hospitals overwhelmed he doesn't give
you the feeling of somebody who's
following all the details and and and
you do worry that he had uh secondary
motives which is obviously he was facing
a re-election I think the combination of
the most divisive president in human
history a election year and uh I I think
that's a recipe for a disaster but the
reason I I particularly put maybe more
blame on fauci is you know presumably he
defines himself he's the adult in the
room and yet he didn't want to have
debates I mean look at how they
demonized Jay and Martin uh he quelched
opposition he put out his own statements
that DeSantis reopen schools in the
spring of 2020 that was the right
decision but he opposed those and so I
mean I expect more from people who are
the adults in the room yeah and you know
he's retired a lot of these people have
moved off the stage of public opinion
but Francis Collins obviously uh at the
NIH is also a big uh you know a big
player in that of trying to swelch
debate could you explain briefly why
even you know kind of like you know
people were liking this to a war event
and you know you don't you don't have uh
long debates during wartime or Etc but
one one of your arguments is that
exactly at these moments when we are
most you know you know struggling with
what to do next and and the future is
uncertain we are our set of knowledge is
incomplete or unclear at Best You've
argued that that's exactly a time when
we need to be opening up debate uh could
you talk a little bit about that
yeah I mean I think we I mean uh for me
it's an obvious point that when you're
facing a situation you've never faced
before and making decisions that are
larger than have ever been made in human
history and unprecedented that that's an
opportunity where smart people will have
the most disagreement not the least
disagreement it's the least settled and
I think what you need is and I suspect
maybe this applies to war too I mean if
I had a bunch of generals around a table
I want somebody there to argue why we're
not doing the right thing so I can hear
the counter arguments and think about it
and even if I do what I'm going to do
anyway I do it knowing some things that
I might have been blind to
um I think Scalia famously used to have
a clerk whose only job was they
disagreed with him but they provided a
balance in science it's so desperately
necessary I I think that to me the
failure of scientific debate has been
the greatest failure around the pandemic
podcasts this this video that you're all
doing you we all did a better job than
universities I mean Stanford Harvard my
own institution I can't think of a
single debate we've had on visitor
policies masking in the hospital School
closure
um masking in communities vaccine uptake
in policies we've had zero debates I'm
in the department of epidemiology who
should be debating this if not the
universities and why are universities
not debating that I think that's part of
a broader Trend where ideas that people
disagree with are viewed as violence and
not something to contend with and outwit
and and persuade and I think that's a
huge problem
um so you had fauci and uh and Collins
they had a point of view a policy they
wanted to advance uh debate would
threaten to reveal their errors and they
chose to quelch debate I want to point
out one more thing they're in a unique
role they're both somebody who's a
pundit on TV telling you what we should
do with schools and they're the head of
the agency that gives scientists their
funding right our funding is dependent
on their institution and so any
scientist who may feel like they
disagree has to weigh the professional
repercussions that they at least believe
could happen in their mind and I think
in the future no one should hold both
those jobs if you want to be a pundit be
a pundit but don't control denyad budget
it's an unnerving situation to be in
because you know that I I had that same
sense as all this unfolded during the
pandemic and I'm just a guy trying to
figure out what to do
um you know for myself for my family
communicating to other people and you
see this playing out you see that debate
being squelched you see the messaging
that is inconsistent uh anyone who's
paying attention you don't have to have
a medical degree to notice uh when
fauci's saying one thing about masks and
then flip flopping and saying something
else about masks so I buy your thesis
that we should not trust Public Health
anymore they they should lose our trust
but it does seem like a really dangerous
place to be because then what do you do
in the void there you know you you are
left with the people on Twitter the
people on the podcasts and you know I I
have a sense of you know who who to
listen to Just I my rule of thumb is
kind of like are they consistently
getting things right
um and you know trying to the best I can
do look at the numbers for you know my
demographic trying to age stratify the
best I can on my own since you know the
the cdc's not doing it so how do we
operate in this world going forward
gosh it's unnerving I I think I mean I
share your view but if you were to
imagine if they're you know there's
people talking about whether or not
there's an escape of bird flu or
something like that if that were really
to happen in this year I think we'll be
it's will be totally destroyed I mean
you'll you'll just see some states doing
the exact opposite of other states
they'll be uh Fierce political
contention around this issue uh they'll
be Revolt from a huge chunk of the
citizenry over any action uh even an
action that is actually the wise action
for a different risk that's totally
different
um people may Revolt over I think we are
so weak and vulnerable
um so you're there's two parts of the
question one is how can they rebuild a
trust trust can be lost in a moment
takes decades to reaccumulate the second
the second thing is what can an
individual do
um the second part first what can an
individual do I mean I used to also
trust the CDC and my trust is shattered
and so what that means is every time I
make a personal medical decision I have
to do a lot more homework and so I have
less and less trust in experts and I
don't like to live that way I mean I'd
like to have some trust in institutions
and experts makes my life harder to go
decide if the Bible and booster is right
for me and figure out who I can follow
and not follow and I'm somebody who's
trained in evidence-based medicine you
know um I'm trained in this sort of
stuff but it's still work uh so I lament
that and I think we all are going to
have to think of ways that we can work
on that for the building trust back I
think we can talk about some structural
fixes but
um it's it's going to take decades I
mean I think that the harms were done
it's going to take decades uh most of my
fixes are you know the CDC look at their
roles their job is to keep track of the
death statistics and also to tell you
what you ought to do we need separate
groups I mean the people keeping track
of the statistics just keep track of
statistics and Report statistics on a
website that any American can download
they've made mistakes in their
statistics you know they were incorrect
about the number of kids who are dead
and they had to provide a revision and
of course their their errors always go
in the direction of their policy and so
an observer might say this is not a
random error this looks like bias like
you're lying to me to get me to do what
you want me to do and the only way to do
that is to build a firewall so the
people who try to advise you are
different than those keeping the
statistics yeah I think there needs to
be a third Group which is the group that
sets out to evaluate the policies and
they should be separate from the group
that institutes the policies the CDC
says schools should wear masks and by
the way our new study that we published
in our own journal says that that was a
good idea I mean what am I to think I
mean you said to do it you did the study
and you put in your own journal and it
has tons of flaws we need Separate
Checks and Balances in public health
just like we do have in government but
it's also I I mean I think what you're
saying is something that a lot of people
miss too is that it is going to take
decades but it's structural and systemic
uh it if it wasn't fouchy if it wasn't
Francis Collins you know it it's likely
we would have still had similar mistakes
made because when you have centralized
control and centralized power and
centralized knowledge you know the the
possibility of COG you know of bias and
uh you know just you know bad decision
making uh being really negative the the
consequence of that are much more likely
I totally agree I mean as much as I do
blame them and I I do blame them at a
personal level and I do think some of
them should be fired um and I've written
that but but I think you're right that
it is a structural problem and you could
have replaced them with other actors who
would have made similar if not worse or
different place yeah we've I mean we've
replaced one president with another and
error continues so right you know meet
the old boss or meet the new boss the
same as the old boss I mean part of my
impression was that one of the saving
Graces here in the United States was the
fact that we do have this Federalist
system where different states could try
different approaches so we had Ron
DeSantis here in Florida trying
something else
um radically different than what
California where I was living at the
time was doing
um and was in contradiction to the guy
the CDC guidance
um and with the vaccine question I I
don't think the census is necessarily
anti-vaccine but he's the Florida's
certainly taking a different approach in
in terms of what it the its state level
agency is recommending for different
ages in terms of the vaccine and so I
just wonder if that given the current
state of the CDC and the FDA if that is
part of the answer is continuing to
devolve power down from them just make
them less powerful give them less
authority to impose mandates you know
issuing guidance or you know keeping
track with Statistics is one thing but
you know imposing any sort of either
mandates or or gatekeeping is where we
really seem to run into problems uh
especially once you get up to the
federal level where you're talking about
330 million people
that's a superb Point
um and I just I mean I totally agree
with you that if you want to strip them
of powers I will support that and I was
the opposite view maybe five years ago
but I just want to point out one way
that kind of backfired was the school
reopening because Biden came into office
and he said he wanted to reopen schools
within 100 days and not even high
schools and he had difficulty because a
lot of local typically left of center
jurisdictions decided that they want to
keep them closed for the rest of this
the year despite the fact teachers were
getting the vaccines first and so
decentralized Authority
um can lead to Innovation because I
think Florida did more things right than
California but it can also lead to uh
chaos because I think San Francisco
schools as an unmitigated disaster
um uh but your point is well taken that
I think I mean the core question is why
humanity is damned right you know we
either have too much power too little
power nobody nobody follows what I want
well you know it's yeah it's a it's a
trade-off because uh you kind of and you
don't always that that's the whole point
of of that kind of more fractured system
is when when you don't have uh kind of
the the best and brightest or the most
honest at the top the best you can hope
for is that somebody at the bottom is
going to figure it out and you can see
you know in real time that it's it's you
know Florida it's sort of working out
San Francisco not so much and I think
this is a good time tonight to point out
that Zach is smarter than you because he
left California and moved to Florida
partly for many reasons but one of them
was uh
certainly play the factor yeah smarter
than me some of us don't have the the
luxury I just want to say about this
topic I mean I think we need to separate
the role of scientists from the role of
uh politics you know scientists can
articulate what the trade-offs are and
maybe do a good job of that but we saw
scientists routinely overstep their role
and also make policy choices which
inherently require values and input of
the public only the public can decide I
think if lockdowns are worth it or if
Hospital visital policies are worth it
uh it's not a scientific question but we
saw over and over the public was
steamrolled uh and I think that's a
great problem and uh you know to take it
back to specifically people who are
identify themselves and are public
health authorities you know one day they
would be saying that you know if 10
people got together to complain about
vaccine mandates that's a super spreader
event they should be arrested the next
day 10 000 people might get together to
protest uh George Floyd's killing you
know which I think is eminently worth uh
you know uh uh demonstrating against but
then they would be like no no that's not
a super spreader event because it's all
about costs and benefits or whatever
um that is you know Public Health as a a
concept has really taken it on the chin
rightly because of the way that public
health authorities and spokespeople talk
during covet can we push a little bit
more in the FDA issue
um do you think ideally and this is an
old libertarian uh you know kind of
rocking horse you know should the FDA
have a monopoly on what kinds of drugs
or medical devices or or practices are
are authorized and made the legal in the
United States or should they be at best
um you know kind of uh you know
recommenders or should they be one uh
you know for medical devices in Europe
there are a number of different agencies
that can recommend that a device is safe
and and can be brought to Market what
what is your sense of how far should we
devolve power away from a
one-size-fits-all decision-making
process at you know at the federal level
I think there's there's two legitimate
things you could argue here one there
can be a group of people who have more
libertarian bent who argue that the
fda's role should be maybe to put a
stamp on something to rate it on a scale
but of course it's a good housekeeping
model or the Underwriters Laboratory
model of of authorizing something of
authorizing something and largely let
the public doctors in concert with the
people they trust make sort of Health
Care choices and to some in some ways
we've moved towards that model because
we have a right to try legislation and
and there's some advances in that space
so that's one world view I think there's
another world view where people who uh
believe more in the power of Regulation
should say something like well like the
FDA is basically trying to prevent sick
desperate people from making choices
that could harm them and so they need to
really make sure that these products
actually work and that the benefits
outweigh the risks and uh and if and
only if they meet that criteria should
they be allowed to be sold on the U.S
market that's the regular way and then
let's just talk about where we are we're
in a middle ground that neither party is
happy because I the regular later side
is not happy because the products coming
to Market there's no Assurance you'll
live longer or live better many products
actually will be found later to have
serious safety concerns or withdrawn
from the market because they didn't
enforce an efficacy requirement the
booster in a 12 year old might turn out
to be a huge miscalculation and they
were wrong so they advise you to do
something with the imprimature of the
agency that turned out not to be correct
in the meantime they do stifle
Innovation because they're setting all
these hurdles that keep small biotech
firms off the market so neither do they
protect the public nor do they allow for
you know the power of the market they're
the worst of Both Worlds they're sort of
a world of uh of crony capitalism and
then they later go work for the company
so I think I mean your argument is well
taken no matter where you are on this
philosophical Spectrum I think the place
they've decided to pitch their tent is
indefensible there was a uh well where
are you though are you do lean more
towards the market or more towards the
regulatory model I always say that I you
know people don't believe me but I
always say that you know I'm uh I'm I'm
a progressive on these issues so I I
mean more to the regulatory issue and
I've written two books on how it could
be done but I mean over the years I mean
I guess disappointment after
disappointment makes you worry that they
won't be able to get their act together
even in a perfect world and so so you
know sometimes I mean it is and I
recommend that people go look at your uh
at your books because I mean a huge part
of your kind of intellectual work your
project is how does medicine how does
Medical Practice get better because bad
interventions hang around like basically
as long or longer than good ones so it's
like okay how do we how do we change
this that's that's a really difficult
question and it's one that I think a lot
of the times we just take for granted
because you know we're living longer for
the most part and and you know we seem
to be getting it right but you know
there's a lot of mistakes and an issue
that I saw some of the FDA Regulators or
advisors struggling with uh as this was
playing out uh I was I watched some of
the meetings about whether or not to
approve the vaccines for the youngest
age group you know six and under or six
to twelve I think might have been the
cohort
um and there were people that wanted to
vote Yes but they were expressing I want
to vote Yes but I don't want this to
mean that the schools are all going to
mandate the vaccine and then of course
that's exactly what happened there was
this pipeline of the FDA gives the
emergency use authorization the CDC then
recommends it and then the local school
districts or even the city of San
Francisco say then you have to give your
kid the vaccine to get into school or if
you're in the city of San Francisco you
have to show proof that they're
vaccinated to go to a public venue
how is is there a way to break that
chain of events because to me that is
that seems like the biggest problem that
I that I saw occurring over and over
again of going from we're going to give
people access to this thing to require
them to get it
yeah I mean I think that was a
catastrophic problem uh thankfully a lot
of the districts that did mandate it
have backed away from it when they saw
what it's going to do to schools which
is going to lead to the expulsion of
tens of thousands of children
predominantly uh Black and Hispanic or
disproportionately Black and Hispanic
and poor uh and so they they finally
came to their senses on the 11th Hour
um but in my mind
that's an example of something that the
evidence was so weak I felt and then the
and the risk in that age group was so
low I felt like you couldn't in good
conscience actually say there's an eua
authority that to be used I mean you
need more data to really even know and
uh as a provider I think you would have
gen you know how will you really counsel
a six-year-old who just had covet a
month ago who can look that family in
the eye and say I know what's right for
you I and nobody knows the answer
um so they could sort of abdicate their
Duty because you know no one else can
make them generate evidence but your
point is well taken that there can be
caveats expressed but the moment they
cast that authorization it's going to
lead to mandates instantly and I think
the only checks and balances I can see
in the system would be one I think we do
have to remove some of the
indemnification because if school
districts were able to be sued if a 16
year old athlete who had covid got the
booster that they were mandated to and
then had myocarditis I think they would
have a lot of pause and they would be
much less likely to mandate um products
under the auspices of eua I think you
might be able to say that nothing under
the auspices of eua should be mandated
by anybody maybe that needs to be able
to be a rule but I do think we get into
a problem when I mean I know people
write to me their kids are going to a
summer camp in Upstate New York and they
have mandates beyond what even the CDC
recommends so who is making these
decisions uh that's a dangerous place
you have written
um multiple times over the past couple
of years about you know what what the
the experience with the pandemic and
with lockdowns and with euas and whatnot
um you know how that is it it is setting
the stage or you look forward to a
future where a lot of democratic norms
and a lot of personal Liberty uh
economic Liberty you name it ends how
are you feeling about the kind of health
of the body politic has the you know has
has the covet experience kind of
weakened us so that we're going to be
more sheepish in the future or has it
kind of kicked in a set of kind of
cultural antibodies you were talking
earlier uh with us about how you know
now people are as likely as not to say
screw you to whatever the government
says where are you on this this kind of
concern right now
yeah
um I'm I'm very worried about what's
outlined in that piece and um you know
just think about it uh we still take our
shoes off in the airports I mean I don't
know if that has done anything or has
any net expected value versus the
thousands of hours which has caused an
enormous amount of personal
embarrassment but uh yeah beyond that
beyond that time I didn't accomplished
much more than that I mean that is a
good thing for the country to be doing
but yeah but we still do it
um so what's the argument in that piece
the argument is that we have a situation
where who decides that their emergency
Powers end it's the governor it's the
president the president has announced
that this emergency will end in in May
um if you have a situation where an
elected official decides when they get
to have massive powers and they decide
what the emergency is and the media can
shape our impression of the emergency
perhaps with misleading statistics or
misleading anecdotes
um how might that be misused I think the
potential for misuse is tremendous
that that piece outlines a hypothetical
scenario I hope it never happens that
you know the governor of a small state
around an election says Hey the
hospitals are filling up with cases and
we have to declare uh you know we're
gonna see we're gonna stop uh Motor
Vehicles because you know we can't just
have extra car accidents in the hospital
we don't have the space uh or other
restrictions they could place
restrictions that could happen around
voting or election Cycles I think we
have underestimated uh the threat of
these powers to be used by an
unscrupulous actor and I think no matter
where anyone sits on the political
Spectrum you can all imagine somebody
you don't want to have the power to
declare unlimited emergency Powers
um and I think we should be more
cognizant of that yeah I mean but do you
think you know coming out of this uh and
I guess you know it's legitimate to say
we're coming out of it you know at
various points Joe Biden has declared
that covet is over various states have
et cetera but do you feel
um do you feel like we're a little bit
stronger like we're a little bit more
cognizant of these threats or do you
feel like no this was actually kind of
setting us up to be even more complacent
going future or more docile if something
you know and maybe if maybe it's not a
pandemic maybe it's a you know an
economic uh catastrophe or something
like that but you know how do you feel
do you think we're we're in a better
position to save that offer where you
know we're more likely to flow with
whatever the government says
I I hope we're in a better position to
David off but I guess my bias is that
I'm surrounded In Pockets of people who
still believe a lot of the things that
are wrong I mean I still go to a
workplace where maybe 15 of people are
masking all the time some I went to the
gym uh and people are wearing cloth
masks while working out I saw somebody
wearing an n95 in a sauna I see people
who are you know chiding others for not
like Rucker Howard at the end of Blade
Runner you know it's like that's
interesting nobody no human should see
um does this square like when you you
said that you know at least in terms of
drug uh regulation you lean a little bit
more towards the progressive end of
things or do you have a personal
politics and um you know how how does
that factor into your kind of framework
and approach to these types of topics
well I'm a lifelong Democrat I'm a
Bernie Sanders supporter and so to see
my side get these issues steadily
incorrect has been catastrophic I mean
we got we're we're the size AI That's
supposed to say we care about poor
disadvantaged minority children we did
the single greatest discriminatory
action in quarter Century which was
closed their schools for 18 months and
guess what they all got coveted anyway
and guess and most of them got covered
before they got vaccines because uptake
is so poor in that age group because the
data is so weak and so what have we done
we're the group that says we're you know
we believe in scientific principles the
same people who say that are critical of
the Cochrane report on masking because
it didn't yield the conclusion they want
and so I guess covid-19 has been a
profound disappointment uh that my side
has any moral or scientific superiority
over any other side and uh and and now
I'm I'm I'm without a party to vinay is
an earlier point we have a magazine that
you might want to subscribe to we have a
newsletter yeah uh to to the the earlier
point about uh states of emergency uh
just persisting endlessly this is uh
from February 28 2023 So Yesterday
California just ended that's uh Governor
I should I should be more specific Gavin
Newsom ended the state of emergency
because that's the situation we're in is
that one person has the ability to do
that with no Democratic check on their
powers and and I I agree with with you
that this is a looming threat coming out
of this that needs to be taken seriously
and I hope there's more
um kind of focus and and you know effort
especially at the state and local level
since that's where these things seem to
drag on and on again like why should a
state of emergency be able to just uh
endlessly persist until the person who
declared it says it's over it seems like
there should be you know a regular
check-in maybe from the legislature to
say okay are we really still all on the
same page here I mean I know that the
California legislature has the power to
do that but it's almost got to be like
baked in to the state of emergency
itself or else I I'm afraid that we we
really are going to fall into that sort
of trap whenever the next catastrophe
hits
absolutely right no I couldn't agree
more with you
yeah and that's a place where the kind
of structural reform where you know
every state of emergency no matter what
has a sunset Clause you know whether
it's you know two weeks or 30 days or 90
days or that it has to be renewed uh God
you have to do that when you lock people
up you know on on a psychiatric holds in
California you know you gotta you got to
drag them in front of a court at least
to to keep them after a certain point
and the principle there's when you
deprive people of Liberty there must be
some check on your ability to deprive
them of Liberty and what we did in the
pandemic was in many ways we deprived
people of Liberty and some core human
Liberties the Liberty to go and visit
your child when they get chemotherapy
and have both parents be there we
deprive them of that Liberty we deprive
them the Liberty to go to shops and
restaurants and go out uh uh and there
has to be checks on those those sorts of
deprivations here okay I guess uh we
should uh wrap up but uh vinay what you
know obviously you're doing this in your
work but you know give a quick Spiel on
how do we remember the past not so that
we endlessly replicate it but so that we
learn from it and actually you know take
the best parts of the path and add it to
New knowledge so that moving forward
we're not stuck in a loop where we're
just endlessly replicating the worst
aspects of of recent trauma
I wish I have the answer to that uh you
know he who forgets history is condemned
to repeat it the santayana quote
um you know I'm trying to do my small
part which is we do research and we want
to do research on these issues that
better clarify which of these things
helped how much they helped and what we
lost in the process what worked what
didn't uh what were the errors made who
made them and when and we're going to
work on putting that in the peer review
literature it's a small part but that's
a literature that's enduring hopefully
will be cited and hopefully we persuade
people and I think we have persuaded a
lot of people because I think more and
more people start to see things the way
that the three of us see things and many
others who follow you all
um but there's still people out there
who live on a bubble they may think that
school closure was wise or that if
anything we didn't mask hard enough or
the real source of misinformation is Joe
Rogan rather than the CDC director I
think that the CDC director in fauci did
more for public trust and help than Joe
Rogan could do in a thousand lifetime I
mean it's not even close and so that's a
battle of the ideas that still has to be
won
um and until you win that battle I think
it's going to be difficult for people to
acknowledge the mistakes they made but
then the last thing I'll leave you with
is I mean I remember when we went into
Iraq and Afghanistan and I remember
there were just a few voices uh who said
that that might be misguided and I also
remember just uh you know uh within the
decade
um it was such a hot issue that if you
had cast a vote for that war you
couldn't be a Presidential nominee and
you ended up that's Hillary lost to uh
Barack Obama and so I do think most of
our coveted response will age in that
way that the pendulum will swing greatly
and there were a lot of people who
stayed on the sidelines
um who do agree and I think they're
going to come out of the woodwork and I
think we will see a big a big change
well thank you that's a uh a kind of
Haunting but also powerful note to end
on vinay Prasad thanks for talking to
Zach weismuller and myself of Reason
thanks for having me